pues hay que mencionar que muchos
analistas electorales criticaban mucho
al partido demócrata porque precisamente
se habían abanderado de El aborto y de
la defensa de la democracia como temas
de campaña decían que esto era muy
alejado de la realidad que los votantes
estadounidenses no sentían esto como
algo que los impulsara a salir a votar
sin embargo pues lo que vemos en estos
resultados electorales es que el aborto
sí era un tema bastante importante que
llevó no solamente a que muchos
estadounidenses salieran a votar para
protegerlo a nivel Estatal sino a que
muchas mujeres y aquí hubo una gran un
gran tema y un gran punto a Resaltar en
estas elecciones las mujeres y los
jóvenes tuvieron una voz muy importante
y fueron los que revirtieron esta
tendencia a los republicanos que estaban
presentando las encuestas una tendencia
que precisamente los demócratas pues van
a pelar a los jóvenes a las mujeres y a
las minorías de cara la carrera
presidencial en el 2024 abanderados de
los temas como la protección a la
democracia y el